Jacuzzi - jacuzzi
it's all right now you get them for some
time
it's all right by you man get me shake
get there son where's my suitcase
you
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
the Lord's Day September 10th 2016
[ __ ] wanna gather shoutout to
America today [ __ ] hang in there and
beside that it's just one of those
[ __ ] days people I couldn't even get
the day started I'm excited I got
jujitsu
a little football some reefer a podcast
EBI the party don't [ __ ] start stop
today I understand me
I'm sitting smoking two types of reefers
today listen to this Godzilla hasn't
made by Chinese people as they're
running down the [ __ ] Street oh and
we also Dax a [ __ ] critical
mass this was killed almost weeks I
would have reacted that's it you know
time to be [ __ ] sitting there all day
last night from doing comedy stone to
the [ __ ] gills I go online and
everybody's talking about this [ __ ]
CM Punk being a bum let me tell you
something I don't even know the [ __ ] CM
Punk is I don't watch rest now it's none
of this [ __ ] all I know is he quit
wrestling to [ __ ] be MMA and he went
up the [ __ ] Rufus
listen the deities had the balls to go
in there I got up to a [ __ ] oxygen I
run away like a little [ __ ] girl the
guy train maybe he wasn't what we
expected but it's not his fault he just
raised his hand thousand people raised
their hands every day they want to be in
the use that don't mean they get in
there Dana put him in that does it or
he'd get a [ __ ] payday but it didn't
work out that way so now the guy's a
[ __ ] scumbag I'm on the internet last
night he's talking about this poor
[ __ ] guy what did he do we wanted AI
beat up what the [ __ ] have you done yo
exam
anyway and I'll put the chatter chatter
Joey who gives a see a bunk get [ __ ]
a you I've seen a lady that nothing to
do with your life at the other [ __ ]
thing when you got a [ __ ] the grocery
store the CM Punk put Dana White there
any of these [ __ ] jack why was there
no so what do you give a [ __ ]
well who gives a [ __ ] this goes in an
item one [ __ ] hear from you know why
this is think all family and your own
[ __ ] life and that's the most
important file pen thing before you sit
there and my [ __ ] yourself about what
the [ __ ] is this gonna do it yeah this I
laid he didn't get up for the national
anthem buddy expect he's a [ __ ]
half-breed and he's adopted this kids
confused as the [ __ ] it is he's looking
for [ __ ] attention so why you sitting
there confused but but when I was
growing up a national anthem we chased
your ass home with that little [ __ ]
briefcase because you would not attend a
Jehovah Witness then obey them what do
you do you know my business
go dude you to get beat up [ __ ] at
least get 20 push-ups on anything and me
going last night my said [ __ ] this I'm
gonna blow over the place I'm not
focused I got a month to [ __ ] get the
SPECIAL together for you [ __ ]
in right now I'm eating [ __ ] [ __ ]
but at least I'm looking at it from that
angle I got something to work up for you
following me all these [ __ ]
everything's beautiful
I killed last night I did this listen
every time I look at myself on that
stage I want to shoot myself in the
[ __ ] head you understand me I hate
looking at myself I hate hearing my
[ __ ] voice but you got a deal
that's why I'm out here smoke I smoke a
bowl before I wanna and listen to my
[ __ ] voice
we shoot this [ __ ] thing and beyond
my tip-top condition
preparation is [ __ ] key even if I'm
not funny that night help me [ __ ]
prepared and that's the most important
[ __ ] thing in life Oh McGregor was
probably shut up the third time and
sometimes you just gotta show up [ __ ]
a lot of people don't like the battle
that's why I was never in a play I don't
like the [ __ ] rarest I just want to
show up there swing pick get my check
and go home but you got to put the work
guys you gotta be cruel to be kind
they all say that showbiz big boy just
another day to [ __ ] sling dick God
gave you another [ __ ] day the sling
thing I went to church under a few
[ __ ] candles I put a nickel on the
[ __ ] box I did the best I could you
know I'm saying that's the best you can
do Jesus saved my life listen I'm
[ __ ] doomed nobody I got a chance up
in purgatory
but beside this that's it net that we
got a podcast night at seven [ __ ]
o'clock p.m. I'm saying 7 o'clock
if you're not busy it's gonna be blue
it's always a good winter why cuz I'm
talking from my heart that's it that's
the [ __ ] that's it I hope you smoke
with me don't forget Austin Texas [ __ ]
August 15 September 15th Thursday Friday
Sally then the following week um in New
York [ __ ] steady at Gotham comedy club
are you kidding me or what
it's so nice we spent this time together
just to get a laugh or sing a song but
before you know it comes the time we
have to save so long little Carol
Burnett see [ __ ] that's how
deep my [ __ ] Jimmy's going today
I just got taken back there I was
thinking about Carol Burnett when I was
a [ __ ] kid and that's the way she
ends her shows oh we're gonna smoke this
then you're gonna go on with your
[ __ ] day okay listen you know I don't
know I planted a beat of my own [ __ ]
drum I have since I'm [ __ ] 15 12
whatever the [ __ ] okay about what you
don't know everybody's doing
I don't want to go to no reefer
I just want to smoke dope family you
guys that's it I keep it at home what
are you gonna do next Tuesday call me
Monday even this is nice pick a buddy
you can cut right now in [ __ ] Peru
get Charlotte where we are with each
other [ __ ] I'm gonna do [ __ ] but
bond with the internet is there Missy
Avila dumped Fox behind keyboards when
they say the dumbest [ __ ] to be cute
because they're not socially accepted
they're gonna hide behind a [ __ ] cape
what it's so [ __ ] bad it's so bad
you'd laugh you sit there and go to
Christ don't these people have a life
people let's go Joey you the [ __ ]
stories yeah because I was after every
[ __ ] day create the [ __ ] life
you're gonna thought was get my ass
kicked on Luzon I was still out there
you [ __ ] there these kids don't leave
the [ __ ] house but what are you gonna
do with me I still got a roll of [ __ ]
jujitsu got beat up by young kids and
get choked and [ __ ] but every day I'd
lose a [ __ ] centimeter of that
stomach and my dignity exam so get it
together [ __ ] there's always a
[ __ ] calculator move
I'll see you guys tonight seven o'clock
be there or be [ __ ] it's we're ready a
rock oh it's not your Monday and you'll
week off on the right foot [ __ ] I
love you stayed black I got [ __ ] two
stones I got stoned earlier to them to
[ __ ] god I'm sorry
I'll see you accepted later